these villagers in mukdahan province in
Thailand's rural northeast are facing an
almost impossible task they have roughly
two hours to comprehend the lengthy and
complicated legal document that could
become Thailand new constitution the
people in this room are just some of the
three hundred and fifty thousand
citizens nationwide who are being
trained to explain the draft charter to
their peers but many here are farmers
are craftsmen without any background in
law but venomoth ah it's hard to
understand a document was written by
professionals that know the law much
better than I do the government hopes
the freshly trained citizens will be
able to convince the people of the
benefits of the draft charter
undemocratic elements like the
overwhelming powers of an unelected
senate are glossed over the drafters of
the constitution are handing out these
little booklets which are meant to
explain key points of the draft on just
14 pages using many little illustrations
and they're highlighting those points
which they apparently think will win the
approval of the people in the referendum
a referendum which many Thais are likely
to see not only as a vote on the draft
charter itself but on the performance of
the military government in general a
performance that not everyone is happy
with tita one set is one of the most
vocal critics of the military government
the former opposition leader frequently
condemned the draft charter on the
opposition movements own TV network but
the government shut the station down for
30 days in its attempt to stifle all
criticism ahead of the vote the move is
in line with a recent law that makes any
attempt to campaign for or against the
draft charter punishable by up to 10
years in prison number one Raymond will
benefit and Emily hey boo muah we
shouldn't even call this a referendum a
referendum can only be held in a
democratic environment with the state
seriously wanting to listen to the voice
of the people remember those who have a
different opinion aren't allowed to
openly express that opinion then it
shouldn't be called a referendum
demio katsudon cam given yummy mummy
quandary i apprec-- amity as in many
parts of Thailand's Northeast villagers
in mukdahan province feel intimidated by
the military rulers even though they
don't approve of the constitution they
are afraid of voicing their opinion
about the referendum I don't want to go
and vote I'm scared I'm only a regular
villager but even the people with higher
positions in the village are scared I'm
afraid of saying something wrong
nowadays anything you say can get you in
trouble it's not like before now the
government is scary the Yan in MOOC
tahan and throughout thailand voters
want free elections to choose a new
government but on Sunday they're being
asked to place their ballots for a
constitution that if accepted would give
them very little say in any possible
future poll